(dramatic music)
- Squaller!
(horse neighs)
(door slamming)
(Alina shrieking)
- [in Fjerdan] Witch!
- Please!
(horse whinnying)
(man groaning)
- No! Please! Please!
I'm not Grisha! I'm a mapmaker!
(man groaning)
- [in Fjerdan] What you are is a witch.
(hooves thundering)
(tense music)
(fighter shouts in Fjerdan)
- [in Fjerdan] Darkling.
(wind rustling)
- And fight!
(dramatic music)
- (women groaning)
- We go again.
- Fight.
(tense music)
(women groaning)
- Your tracker friend also liked it
when I put him on his back.
(dramatic music)
(punch thwacking)
(claws thrusting)
(alternate dimension shrieking)
(blade sheathing)
(blows thumping)
(blade chinking)
(table clattering)
(bottle clinking)
(Mal groaning)
- Tofin.
Shit.
(blade chinking)
(Mal groaning)
(tense music)
(table leg clacking)
(blade swishing)
(Mal groaning)
(punches thudding)
(Mal gasping)
(Mal yelling)
(flesh rippling)
(punch thwacking)
(blade clanging)
(eerie music)
(deer whining)
(gun blasting)
(man groaning)
- That animal's not meant for you.
(arrow plunging)
(Mal groaning)
- [Alina] Mal!
(tense music)
(Alina panting)
- You chose to betray our people.
I was trying to save us.
(Kirigan groaning)
- Mal!
- You betrayed us first.
(sinister music)
(punching)
(Alina panting)
(Alina retching)
- How dare you?
He gave you everything.
Remember your place.
(gun blasting)
(gun twirling)
- Still couldn't shoot the pretty face.
I've got to stop doing that.
(dramatic music)
(men groaning)
(punches thumping)
(beast screeching)